I believe that the best way to increase your ability to come up with more and better ideas...
...is to simply practice, practice, practice.
If we compare the world of business to the worlds of athletics and the arts,...
...one glaring difference shines through.
In athletics and in most artistic endeavors, we practice much more than we perform.
As a college football player, I would practice for two months before the first game...
...and then five times a week for one game on Saturday.
As an actor and improvisor, I've learned that practicing and warming up before I perform...
...is as important as my performance skills or talents.
One of the simple things we can do...
...to make sure that we take the time to practice our innovation skills...
...is to create project models and schedules that have built-in components...
...and time allotments for idea generation and refinement.
Too often I see groups moving directly to the implementation stage...
...or the action steps of the process.
Practicing innovation can be easy.
You can simply commit to a two-minute brainstorming session before each meeting.
Warming up for innovation,...
...it can be as utilitarian as asking everyone to turn off their cell phones...
...and engaging in a non-work conversation before the meeting begins.
You'll be surprised at what can happen.